i'd like to introduce you to your new
assistant drum roll please
that's your drum roll when a tempo isn't
specified any reasonable person would
default to lento well it's terrible and
you ruined a fun thing but i would still
like to introduce you to mr gordon lunt
mr gordon lunt
gordon you want to come in here oh i'm
so sorry i was just deciding whether i
should just go home the tone and tenor
of your introduction make me worry that
this is a fun office which i would not
enjoy
huh hello i'm captain raymond holt and i
can assure you this is not a fun office
thank goodness in that case my interest
is renewed here is my resume oh i'm
feeling this are you guys feeling this
gordon why don't you tell captain holt a
little bit about yourself where to begin
i'm 174 centimeters tall i can type 103
words per minute with an error rate of
1.6
and i recently moved here from
philadelphia which is the sixth most
populous u.s city i understand the city
of philadelphia is coterminous with
philadelphia county making it the eighth
largest metropolitan statistical area
yeah philly's cool isn't it fun just
telling each other facts yes well i
think i have all the information i need
thank you for coming in mr larry my
pleasure
so
looks like operation nasty is a full-on
success huh you mean operation nasty sex
a lot of while by now didn't you see him
flirting with me no i most definitely
did not and you're a blind man and a
prude to boot did you see his tie a
single windsor the easiest not to undo
why bother wearing any clothes at home i
think you badly misread that interaction
please he did everything but lick his
lips and purr get rid of him and bring
to someone who can keep it in their
slacks do you hear there's a barrel
making exhibit at the brooklyn museum of
industry yes
has he no shame the door was open i
think he wanted people to hear yeah i
stole those coins i can't believe you
bought that old story they
underestimated you randy just as they
underestimated raymond holt you guys
haven't been that great to me either
well you got to teach people how you
want to be treated randy dr phil r.i.p
the point is captain holt solved the
case when no one else could he's
actually been stealing from these
archives for years you've been asleep at
the wheel alastair you're an
embarrassment really well at least i've
never confused scent augustine with
boethius oh who gives a rat's ass about
boethius wesley what are you doing kevin
i'm creating a kerfuffle oh damn sure my
husband is a hot piece of ass but he is
so much more than just that raymond holt
is as smart as anyone in this department
but he chooses to use his intelligence
to make our city a better place
one day i hope to live up to the
standard you set
you make me want to have
a wetter brain
i'm kevin
[Music]
y'all are hella specific
look at us
three rogue cops taken on a case the
commissioner told us to drop light up
your jacket sit up straight judge mendel
has a reputation for being strict and
proper all right no worries i'll just
act like you say something so i can get
the cadence of your voice down i will
not perfect i will not
i will not i will
not
have a seat detective i will not excuse
me uh sorry
i meant out of respect i will choose to
stand sit
i will not
this looks like it was filled out by a
toddler now we're going to have to go
through this point by point
justice cannot be rushed but
could it be gently nudged into
hyperspeed i take it you're the toddler
excuse me a moment
this is going terribly new plan
i'm gonna charm her
oh no
i'm sorry i had to take that you got to
do what you got to do captain raymond
holt
what's up
look at that they put the sherry barrels
right up front ugh i hate it when
museums pander to the tourists oh i
think you need to check your bag gordon
it's a small price to pay to make sure
the barrels are protected my thoughts
exactly
the package is headed your way copy that
this better work i'm debasing myself out
here what most people think
oh i prefer to discuss this matter in
private anything you have to say to me
you can say in front of peralta very
well
i've been sent here to spy on you what i
am truly shocked we are both shocked
commissioner kelly knows you're
recruiting a team of captains to oppose
him he asked me to find out who they are
but i've decided i won't help him why
not because i've fallen in love with you
what
that is truly shocking for real this
time what so nice of you to stop by
kevin enjoy your day i hope it's
productive thank you raymond i hope your
day is productive as well
pda in the office my my i couldn't help
myself
i got to hand it to you captain that was
some ceremony it wasn't difficult i
simply said what i wish had been said
when kevin and i got married oh well
then i never would have heard your
hilarious efficient officiant quip
you're right i regret nothing
but all this does make me think i might
enjoy a more
festive expression of our commitment to
one another are you suggesting we hold
an honest-to-goodness wedding
nothing too elaborate we're not the
kardashian west's after all
they are a musician and a celebrity
personality who recently wedded yes yes
i know
they were answers on jeopardy i think
you mean questions
you guys are fun
can i help you
i'm just trying to work up the nerve to
see her see who my female wife crystal
i was cheating on her with a waitress
from wing named jamie lynn one
night when i was
philandering crystal caught me kissing
jamie lynn's
heavy breasts she flew into a rage and
now she's serving five years for
aggravated assault yeah i'm sorry to
hear that yeah thanks man it's funny
when we first met we had some good times
[Music]
looks like we both want that stapler
seems that way based on what happened
so when did it all go south 1989.
i was up for a big promotion which would
have fast-tracked my career once offered
to write a letter on my behalf but
instead she torpedoed me because of
something that happened the night before
she was to turn it in
madeleine
[Music]
would you care for a drink i'd love one
i'm sure you can tell i'm quite drunk
i've had a couple to build up the nerve
i think we both know what i'm about to
say
raymond
i don't think we need to say anything
i'm gay
that's what i was going to tell you
well then
she sabotaged my career because i
refused to
bed her
you